Gordon Ramsay has been making us laugh
and cringe in fear since 1999. since
then he has absolutely mastered the art
of insults fixing restaurants and
entertaining Young Chefs the only thing
he's not good at is seeing when his
daughter's about to prank him not gonna
lie it's hard to go through all the
Gordon Ramsay shows of which he's had
like 285 and find the best moments but I
think there's one that needs to be
included more than anything else that
wasn't even on one of his shows that
would be the recipe for Ramsay's best
ever dish the idiot sandwich during an
appearance on James corden's The Late
Late Show Chef Ramsay showed how good he
is at making fun of himself during the
segment hell's cafeteria in the segment
James Corden and Julie Chen play
contestants in this fake cooking
competition show set in a cafeteria in
one section Gordon puts two pieces of
bread on Chen's head and asks what are
you she iconically responds an idiot
sandwich even that that wasn't right it
was Chuck Ramsay even being made into an
idiot sandwich isn't as bad as failing a
Gordon Ramsay test on camera Kitchen
Nightmares wasn't really a show that
made me laugh as often as it made me
cringe in absolute Terror at the most
disgusting things I'd ever seen in my
life I will never be able to unsee that
maggoty kitchen that made even Gordon
throw up
there's one moment from the show that I
will always find hilarious though Ramsay
is always a fan of good competitions and
he staged what should have been an easy
blind taste testing competition he had
chicken and beef easily labeled on a
plate and a blindfolded head chef in
front of him he had the chef try the
sample and identify what it was I didn't
know what to expect when he blindfolded
us the head chef tries the chicken and
confidently identifies it as beef wrong
then he gets another chance for the New
York strip of steak which he thinks is
pork like I can't imagine owning myself
that hard on live television especially
not in front of one of the most famous
chefs alive at least he can have some
comfort in the fact that Gordon's own
daughter managed to own him a few years
later Gordon Ramsay isn't the only star
in the family if you don't follow his
daughter Tilly Ramsay on Tick Tock what
are you even doing she frequently shares
videos with her dad usually dancing
traveling or like cooking with him there
was this one time she totally owned him
with an epic prank though she took a
bottle of water and an egg and made it
seem like she pushed the egg into the
water bottle without breaking it when
Gordon looked over the bottle to inspect
it she squeezed the bottle spraying him
with water and smashed the egg that
she's kept in her other hand the whole
time on his head clearly no one has ever
owned Gordon this hard because he seems
completely stunned by it that is one
brave brave girl right there and like
all her career in reality television
needs now is a killer catchphrase or in
her dad's case a go-to insult there have
been a ton of masterpieces made on
Hell's Kitchen but there was one moment
where I think the clouds cleared above
the restaurant and the sun anointed
Gordon in holy Golden Light that would
be the moment when a chef showed him an
unseasoned dish and he responded by
calling her
and you just know the minute he said it
in that thick accent of his The
Producers immediately high-fived like
the they did the first time Emery said
bam that led to years of hilarity as
Gordon's insult of choice anytime he
needed a quick jab to throw at someone
though every once in a while someone
tries to throw a jab at him so my
absolute favorite moment from Hell's
Kitchen came when former Marine Joseph
tinelli was kicked off the show while
some people graciously take this news
with a tear or a shrug old Joe was
Furious in fact he stormed off the stage
and charged at Gordon Ramsay as if he
were going to attack him it's obvious
that he was hoping to see the normally
Fierce Ramsay back away from him in fear
but yeah that's not what happened you
see what Joe didn't know was that Ramsay
had a lot of fighting experience yeah
the guy is a black belt in karate and
regularly practices mixed martial arts
so when tonelli tried to run up on
Ramsay Gordon didn't even Flinch you can
see the exact moment that tonelli
realized he messed up sure security got
between them and escorted to Nelly out
but I think they were there more for his
safety than for Gordons look at Ramsay's
face guys that dude was ready to
roundhouse kick a fool still Gordon will
always prefer rude contestants to the
true bane of his existence rude
customers the worst thing you could ever
do on Hell's Kitchen is be a customer
who has the audacity to walk up to the
kitchen and try to get Gordon's
attention to his credit he almost always
ignores the first attempt to talk to him
as a non-verbal warning that you do not
belong there if you persist he will
obliterate you with expletive filled
insults most of them I can't repeat but
my favorite PG insult is when a tall
woman makes this exact mistake and tries
to get Ramsay's attention he then looked
at the server and told them take the
draft back to the table please and he
did so just loud enough so she
definitely heard him she should know
that the only people Gordon has any
Mercy for are children my favorite thing
about Gordon Ramsay is that he is
terrifying on 98 of his shows then
there's Master Chef Junior or where he
is about as kind and kid-friendly as a
Pixar movie Take This Moment which would
have resulted from bodily harm on Hell's
Kitchen when a contestant slams a creamy
cake all over his face if that wasn't
bad enough the other kids all hit him
with cake until he is completely covered
though it seems like he thought the
whole thing was funny just in case could
someone check on those kids and get back
to me yeah Gordon Ramsay seems like the
exact sort of person who gets angry at
other people's dogs but considers his
own to be perfect little angels who've
never done anything wrong in their
entire lives